manon massé passe le flambeau j'ai des
fourmis neige mais en ce moment je suis
dans un rôle qui me un rôle qui parfois
me mettais elle reste co porte parole
elle demeure député
mais en septembre c'est gabriel nadeau
dubois qui prendra sa place comme chef
parlementaire charge solidaire lors de
notre prochain congrès je veux non
seulement solliciter un nouveau mandat à
titre de porte parole
je vais également vous demander votre
confiance comme candidat d'un autre
parti au poste de premier ministre de
guinée les rôles changent mais ils
feront toujours équipe pour rallier les
troupes
le parti sans appel d'un épisode de
querelles internes
c'est adopté à la majorité la motion de
blâme contre le collectif anti raciste
et coloniale a été adopté dans une
proportion de 81 %
mais le débat laisse un goût amer à
certains militants je suis déçu et fâché
de voir des façons dans ce set story
débauche de près c'est qu'on fait
plusieurs délégués ont exprimé leur
malaise c'est la démarche qui consiste
donc à 510 publiquement à la vue de sa
politique collectif apple qui me dérange
cette façon de faire peut créer des
blessures difficiles à la commission
nationale des femmes arrivées
positionner sur le sujet je vous parle
aussi de mes collègues députés
la député rob bagg azal de son côté a
parlé d'un inconfort persistante des
élus face au collectif
ça fait très longtemps apparences c'est
la goutte qui fait déborder le vase qui
se sentent portés par les façons de
farges le tas initialement prévu pour la
délibérant été coulée le débat qui
devait initialement être clos en 30
minutes a été prolongé son veut donner
une prolongation de vingt minutes et je
suis rendu au tour de parole des 1000
poirier en fait pour moi une motion
blanc c'est juste de nommer mme aux
malades de camarades à camara tous n'ont
pas la tête à la camaraderie
moi j'ai le goût de bublé macquart
demande juste parce que l'objectif du
conseil national était de commencer à
préparer les troupes pour les prochaines
élections malgré le tumulte les délégués
se sont entendus pour mettre
l'environnement au coeur du programme
on verra c'est les membres du collectif
antiraciste
et colonial rentreront dans les rangs ou
quitteront le parti d'ici là ici valérie
gamache radio canada québec